what's up alienation I started to mentor
me serious with the goal to try to learn
from people who've done a lot more than
us hang around them a little bit longer
I'm by being in their environment
hopefully some of their mindsets their
beliefs our way of thinking seep into us
to help us become the best version of
ourselves so today we're going to learn
how to be unshakable with tony robbins
mentor me Tony and as always guys as
you're watching the clip if you hear
something that really really resonates
with you please leave it down in the
comments below and put quotes around it
to other people can be inspired and also
when you write it down you're much more
likely to lock it in for yourself to
enjoy
[Music]
you
Tony the idea of being unshakeable it's
clearly more than money but in this
context what is it truly mean to be
unshakable it's a state of mind it
relates to money because most people
when they're trying to figure out how to
create financial freedom create more
stress for themselves worrying about
what's going on and when you're truly
unshakable you have the mindset where
you understand how the market works you
understand that real estate can go up or
down stocks can go up or down but your
family can still do well unshakable is a
bear market can come a correction can
come and there's no fear in you or if
there is a little fear we're all human
you don't stay there you find a way to
break through you find your Center and
when you have that Center you do what's
right to be able to take care of
yourself and your family and I was
interviewing about a year and a half ago
you know the former Fed chair Alan
Greenspan who for 19 years the most
powerful man in finance in the world
under four different presidents spent
five hours with him about three
privately and two on stage in front of a
group and one of my final questions to
him and we talked about all this crazy
change and all this volatility and how
do people get things together I said
look if you were back head of the Fed
today what would you do and there was
this long pause he pause we pause they
lean to me and said Tony I designed that
did not build much confidence for me or
anybody else should be watching and yet
in the midst of all that as you well
know there's a few unicorns in the
financial market very few these people
that have found a way to do well over
all the decades and good times and in
bad and they know what it takes to be
unshakeable and it isn't just guts or
confidence it's understanding certain
facts that when you know them they for
you the metaphor I give people is that
you know if you go yeah most of us have
heard the old Sufi metaphor of you know
the man is walking along in the middle
of a night and he sees a snake and
freaks out runs away and he comes in in
the morning and what does he see it was
a rope and so once you know it's a rope
you'll be there middle of the night
you're not scared again this book
unshakable is this it's really a
financial freedom play book for anybody
it's the real essentials about how to go
from where you are to where you really
want to be but how to do it with peace
of mind how to do it even when things
are volatile
enjoy yourself I want to write a book
that would protect people because we all
know a crash is coming and if you're not
in the market you're still going to
experience it if you're not prepared for
it because it affects the economy as a
whole and every five years we have on
average we have a bear market or a crash
and it lasts a year and it drops 33% but
every single one of those you don't lose
any money unless you sell it's really
important for Americans to understand
this because America is unique and two
and a half centuries every crash is
followed immediately by an explosion up
in a bull market so you all remember
2008 remember the market you know
dropped almost 50% to keep the traffic
you're aware of it but from March 9th
but a day or two from now the
celebration of it he went up in the next
12 months 69 percent and it's been going
up ever since for two hundred and fifty
percent so you get really wealthy when
those numbers change so what I want to
do is free people from the fear not buy
enthusiasm or positive thinking buy
facts the facts are there's a correction
every year you shouldn't be surprised
the market crash last year anyway is the
worst opening and they history the stock
market and we had a record-breaking year
people lost 2.2 trillion if they sold
but if they stayed they went nowhere so
when you know that every single year
there's going to be a correction now
correction by the way means it drops 10
up to 20% on the peak a bear market or
crashes 20% or more but every year since
1904 116 years we've had a correction
it's like winter you're not surprised
when winter comes summer long summer
short but you know what's coming you'll
even had a chapter in the book called
winter it is my HBO special but but the
reason I say that is if you know it's
coming we want to prepare so you're
protected but also for everyone
listening everyone who's joining us
online think about this if you're a
millennial for example you got all this
debt from college it's so imbalanced
right now and you think you're never
going to get free or you're a baby
boomer and you never got started you
think it's too late believe it or not
the crash the next crash is the greatest
opportunity in your life to leapfrog
from where you are where you don't want
to be financially to where you want to
be because everything goes on sale
listen the ladies in this room if your
favorite outfits or shoes are on sale
for 50% off you pretty damn excited
right
well guys if I said to you what's your
favorite card you said a Ferrari and I
say again for 50% off guys if you add
they're mine but when the stock market
drops 50% it's on sale most people freak
out not Warren Buffett not people like
that I interviewed a guy named Howard
Marks he was investing a billion dollars
a week in 2008 and 9 when the market was
through the floor now he's worth a
hundred billion dollars because he
bought everything for pennies you got to
get this way when things are going
really great what do people want for the
price of their home or the price of
their stock or their business it's real
value or more when it's going off like
crazy everybody wants more than it's
worth when it starts crashing what will
people take for their car for their
business for their stocks all the day
anything they can get and so those
opportunities are the greatest one thing
up in your life and he's just going to
know if you're stressed by worrying
about the market or the economy there's
a correction every year you're going to
be stressed forever here give 35 and you
live to 85 you got 50 more Corrections
to go through and you know a bear market
comes every five years so you're going
to depend more bear markets in your life
time to stop being stressed time to
become unshakable which simply means you
have a plan you know what's going on
you're not fearful because you know how
this works long term and you're not
going to be taken advantage of you're
going to take advantage of the
environment a goal if you own a business
and I resume a lot of your viewers are
business owners or for getting started
in business remember how good you are in
business think about this the one
universal rule the idiots in finance
know is diversification the only free
lunch you've got a diversified because
if you put all your eggs in one basket
no matter how good the basket is one day
that real estate market that stock
market that bond market that
collectibles market whatever you invest
in right now you showed me statistically
it'll drop 50 to 70 percent on a day now
if you're later in life if that happens
it's over for you but so you have to
diversify yet most people they know real
estate till they do it or they know
stocks they do it or they grip the hand
their parents flipping things it's the
wrong thing to do so you've got to
diversify in order for you to be able to
truly succeed and that's why when you
want to business yeah if you put all
your money in your business which is
what most of us do naturally you see a
lot of register you put all your eggs in
one basket and there's things that can
happen I mean you know you're
you spend 20 years and you figured out
how to put together the ultimate map you
know and remember Garmin came out with a
thing called the TomTom and remember you
see on your you almost remember that
before anything yet or just put on your
dash now yet across 100 bucks it was a
breakthrough they were making like
another nine or something oh yeah here
yeah six months later what happened the
iPhone came out we have Google Apps
these little bastard my friendship came
out with it put Google Maps with their
own map on here and how much zero what
they going to do to your business when
someone takes your product deserving
give away for free so I always tell
people competition happens and
technology happens what you must do is
have a second business we know with no
moving parts no people no time maybe it
takes you two to three days a year for
two or three hours after you've read the
book you put it in place and you measure
it two three times you know that's it
yeah go on with your life now there's no
trouble in your business you're
financially set I in my life
at thirty-one companies now we have you
know what do we have 1200 employees
seven different industries we have five
billion in sales I mean I used to be you
know me and my seminar business it's
grown geometrically with all those
moving parts the only way I've been able
to succeed is because I've taken
everyone those businesses diversified my
assets so that when things were in
trouble I spent enough economics take
care myself and keep the business going
so everybody needs to create a money
machine that works while you sleep it
doesn't have moving parts and that's
what this is really about can you talk
about what it means to discuss the
market as a game and how that might be a
dangerous concept sure what first of all
the reason I called the other book money
master the game is every wealthy person
I interviewed call to the game every
single one and other people were saying
that's irresponsible that's horrible to
call it a game this is a dumbest thing
that's an but see that mindset is what's
keeping you from investing in the first
place so you could be in a game it could
be a difficult game a challenging games
are usually the ones that we like the
most but this is a game that can reward
your family disproportionately to any
other game that's out there now some
people play games aggressively some play
things more in a secure way your style
is more secure and what I teach in this
book is we want have a style that makes
you feel good
a bunch of money but you're stressed all
the time it's not worth it there's a way
to make money your slave instead of you
being the slave to money but let me
explain it's not putting all your money
in the market it's really two things its
first you've got to decide the most
important financial decision of your
life and that is to become an owner and
not just a consumer if you have a I see
a bunch of iPhones recording the
treasure water your foot you know here's
your glass of water now if you're a I'm
an active human seasoned with me but if
you've got an iPhone you don't own Apple
or better yet you don't own the index of
the S&P 500 the best 500 companies
you're making a giant mistake because
you'll never earn your way to financial
fortune even people that make just loads
of money the actors the actresses the
athletes where are they 10 and 15 years
later I mean 50 cent made a hundred
million dollars on vitamin water he got
a tip and he got like a two or three
hundred million dollar net worth and
he's bankrupt
he bought Mike Tyson's house 25 thousand
square feet and Mike Tyson made a half a
billion dollars in went bankrupt right
now I know if you saw Johnny Depp I
don't know it's going to happen up at
the papers are saying he may go bankrupt
he made three quarters of a billion
dollars as a movie star but he spent
thirty thousand dollars a month
unwind he must be feeling good and
secondly he took Hunter Thompson the
reporter he burned his body and paid
three million dollars to blow his ashes
into the sky in a cannon so know how
much money you make you can screw it up
right but if you will just decide
there's a percentage of my income that
no matter what I'm going to have it
automated I'm not going to see it if
things go straight to an investment
account and I don't know if it's 10 or
15 or 20 those numbers sound gigantic to
most people even if you start with five
and built that income does not go to
anybody else and then you put that into
compounding so listen to this there's a
young man true story a theater Johnson
1950s worked for ups never made more
than $14,000 in annual income in his
entire life retired with 70 million
dollars and he didn't you know he didn't
inherit a dime he gave away thirty five
million while he's alive now how is that
possible because of compound interest
whenever all these investors would say
what's the biggest mistake Americans
Bank he said
but they all said they don't cap in a
compound ginger so you know
intellectually a little bit what it
means but they don't do it they don't do
it consistently so what do you think
they just means that the profits you
made go back into the reinvesting and it
keeps growing but it grows geometrically
right and so a friend of his came to
this man who worked for ups and said I'm
gonna make you rich we're gonna put a
20% tax on you he said I can't give up
20% I kept him at those if I do that he
said listen to the government raise your
taxes 20% and you claimed you screamed
you cry you complain and you pay it and
you get adjusted to it but he said this
like I'm the government this is going
into an account for your future and that
compounding is what made him that much
money in the book I give you an example
of a an 18 year old boy whose father
convinces him that he should save 300
ollars a month out of his income she's
not a huge income that sounds like a lot
but when you automate it you forget
about it's perfect you just well he does
this from 18 years old to 27 for 8 years
so the total amount of money $300 a
months about 4,000 a year that's $28,000
total he didn't put ELISA to the market
and never adds a dime to it from 28
years old on at 65 because the market
over those 30 years grew 10% his money
has compounded so much he has 1.8
million dollars you don't need a lot of
money to be wealthy you need time so
you're saying that even if I have
student debt that I'm struggling to pay
off even if I'm making say $1,000 a week
that I should still try to put a
percentage or make it a point to put a
percentage not just into a savings
account but into an investment into an
investment account where to put that
money then we teach you the ways to do
that it's got to be diversified yeah
never put all your money in the mark
okay one of the five takeaways that
somebody can take from this book where
they can really put them actually into
action well I'll tell you the four
things that I enjoyed these 50
unbelievable investors had in common
they're all different
you know I interviewed people that are
macro traders and if you'd people like
Warren Buffett write value people
interview people that have blood in the
streets type of people you buy when the
world is going to hell and they're all
different but they have four things in
common real fast number one every single
one of them was obsessed with not losing
money
guys like you and I tend to say how do
we make money for our companies for
ourselves as an investor
their entire focus is not losing money
because they know if you lose 50% it
takes a hundred percent get even tell us
about becoming comfortable at rest well
it's more than that these guys are
obsessed with not being comfortable risk
they don't want to take relax its second
key that they do is they all are focused
on asymmetrical risk reward
most people think the most successful
investors take huge risks to get huge
rewards and in reality they take the
least risk humanly possible to get the
largest upside so their whole focus is
how do I get a three to one or a five to
one if I risk $1 try to make five and
I'm wrong i grifted I can be wrong four
times and break even so they have a
completely different approach they're
all very focused thirdly on tax
efficiency because you only have the one
you get to keep and fourthly it's all
diversification and those four things
fundamentally are the frame from which
you start to design a portfolio how did
you go from basically not having a hot
meal to you know basically being a guru
an international guru doling out
financial advice what's interesting I
was just worth magazine just named me of
their power 100 100 most influential
people in global finance along with Carl
all the guys I interviewed but part of
it is I believe in modeling I believe
success leaves clues if someone has done
very well financially for decade after
decade they're not lucky they're doing
something different if someone is fit
and healthy and they manage it for 20
years they're like I got a great
relationship they're not lucky so I'm
really good at deciphering what those
things are so I would go sit down with
someone like Jack Vogel you know a
little built you know three you know
trillion dollar industry right you know
what he's doing there Vanguard and I
still have a 45-minute interview and we
go for hours and he says he's in the
business sixty-five years and in the
book he says it was the most penetrating
emotional he has ever done his life
because I kind of extract it out of
their brain and they make it simple so
you can apply so thank you guys so much
for watching I'd love to know what did
you learn from this video what Clips
spoke to you the most and what you're
going to take from these clips and
immediately apply to your life or to
your business somehow leave it down in
the comments below I'm super curious to
find that finally I want to give a quick
shredder to Trident Lion thank you so
much for picking up copy of my books
gear one word and for making that often
youtube video on it as well
I really appreciate the support and I'm
glad that you enjoyed the book today
this video is all about your one word
[Music]
so thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love